Also wer denkt, dass wir jetzt anfangen können?
Lol.
So einfach ist es natürlich nicht.
The GPU instance has been suspended.
Aha.
Das ist sehr interessant.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass meine Grafiker
sich ausschalten können.
Dann müssen wir das Game halt nochmal neu starten
und nochmal neu die Mikrofonsettings machen,
weil das Game die wieder umstellen wird gleich.
Lol.
Einfach nur Lol.
Lol 3D.
Übrigens, mir fällt gerade auf,
Twitch hat sich bei mir auf Twitch Beta umgestellt,
sehe ich gerade im Browser.
Und jetzt geht Better Twitch TV nicht mehr.
Das geht das.
Moment, das muss ich umstellen.
Das muss ich umstellen.
Das geht nämlich nicht.
Ohne Better Twitch TV kann ich den Chat nicht lesen.
Das ist nicht möglich.
Ah, man kann Beta ausschalten.
Das ist gut.
Beta ausschalten.
Und jetzt mal Kanal refreshen.
Und jetzt sollte ich auch wieder
Better Twitch TV E-Mails haben.
Hoffe ich.
Na ja, geht das jetzt?
Probieren wir mal aus.
Ja, funktioniert.
Perfekt.
Nice.
Richtig nice.
So, es ist noch relativ früh.
Ich muss noch aufwachen.
Was gibt es?
Was gibt es Besseres zum Aufwachen,
als eine neue Runde LoL 3D zu spielen?
PogChamp, BestChamp.
Jetzt fehlen bloß noch,
jetzt fehlen bloß noch diese Benutzernamen,
sowas nach dem Motto irgendwie,
notify me when Max dies,
so irgendwie sowas, ja.
Ist ja ein totaler Trend in größeren Channels zur Zeit.
Oder whisper me when an A-Ult,
oder sowas in der Richtung.
Gut, jetzt habe ich wenigstens wieder Emotes.
Das ist wichtig.
Ohne Emotes, ohne Better Twitch TV Emotes geht nix.
Allerwichtigstes.
So, da war's er.
Muss trinken.
So.
Da wollen wir mal, würde ich sagen.
Go, go.
Wir gucken uns erst nochmal,
das wollte ich nämlich das letzte Mal schon machen,
das war Vollbild einschalten.
Ich muss einmal noch gucken,
ob das auch meine Grafik-Settings beibehalten hat.
Ja, jetzt scheiße ich einfach ausschalten.
Brauchen wir alles nicht.
Was auch immer.
Shadows, wer braucht Shadows?
Shadows, komm jetzt.
Ich brauch keine Shadows.
Ich will, dass das, ich brauch mehr FPS.
Meine Grafikkarte ist zu schlecht.
Das ist nicht nur die teuerste Grafikkarte, die es gibt,
aber, ja, zu schlecht für das Game.
Am besten ist ja, dass ich überhaupt keine Ahnung hab,
was uns diese Option eigentlich alles sagen soll.
Quality Shadows.
Da brauchst du was.
Shadows off.
Wobei, Shadows sind manchmal ganz praktisch,
wenn man schon sieht, dass einer um die Ecke kommt,
bevor man ihn sieht. Shadows lassen wir mal an.
Ja, Textur, Filter, Zeugs.
Machen wir nochmal.
Keine Ahnung.
Nein, das will ich nicht.
Textur stellen wir mal nur auf High.
Auch nochmal auf High runter.
Komm, wir stellen es mal auf Normal.
Wir gucken mal, ob das Auswirkungen auf die Performance hat.
Weil die Performance das letzte Mal war wirklich grottenschlecht.
Und dann wollte ich nochmal den Soldat anpassen.
Oh, das ist nicht einfach nur Airborne,
das ist Airborne HD.
Airborne HD.
Was nehmen wir denn mal?
Was können wir denn hier schönes anlocken?
Ich hoffe ja, insgeheim immer wieder,
dass das die einzigen Waffen sind.
HQ, nein, nein, das ist HD.
Die haben es bestimmt nur verschrieben.
Ich hoffe ja immer noch, dass es die einzigen Waffen sind,
die es geben wird am Ende.
Aber ich glaube es ja nicht.
Dann wäre das nämlich wirklich,
das mal halbwegs sinnvoll zu balancen.
Dann wäre das nämlich wirklich, das mal halbwegs sinnvoll zu balancen.
Nennen wir mal das Ding.
Wo sehe ich eigentlich meine 13 Tokens?
Gibt es in... Wenigstens haben sie auf
in-game-Waffen-Statistiken gleich verzichtet.
Weil die in-game-Waffen-Statistiken waren eh immer kaputt.
Irgendwie sieht das Bild nicht so aus wie die Waffe, oder?
Ja, ne wirklich.
Scope.
Ah ok, das heißt die Aufsätze
muss man sich freispielen mit der Waffe.
Ok, ok.
Na dann leveln wir das Ding erst nochmal ein bisschen.
Haben wir da Aufsätze? Oh Scopes!
Ob sowas im Zweiten Weltkrieg schon gab?
Gibt es sowas wie Quick?
Wie hieß das so? Nach dem Sprint schneller Waffe ziehen?
Or Rapid Fire? Nice, nice, nice.
Dann spielen wir erstmal das hier mit frei.
Quick Draw.
Was kannst du mir bei meinem PC helfen? Habt ihr ein Problem?
Das ist Remote immer so ein bisschen schwierig, ne?
Ach hier unten steht dann auch was die Waffe kann.
Das ist einfach immer gelogen.
Das ist in allen Games.
Also ich kann hier drauf das ganze genauer machen, was ja Blödsinn ist.
Ich kann hier drauf das ganze genauer machen, was ja Blödsinn ist.
Das machts auch nicht genauer.
Und die Range wird auch nicht höher, man siehts einfach nur besser.
Oh Steady Aim, das brauche ich.
Ganz ganz wichtig.
Das heißt wir haben jetzt
Wir haben jetzt Quick Draw,
Faster und besser aus Hüfte da.
Das klingt eigentlich ganz gut.
Probieren wir das mal in der Kombination.
Pistolen gibt es nur zwei.
Granaten gibts
Easy, auf geht's
Spielen wir mal ne Runde Team Deathmatch so zum warm werden
Oh, das ging aber schnell
Sprayen, sprayen, klar
Oh, da gibts
Ich wollte gerade sagen, es gibt viele Comments, aber ich muss hier erstmal bashen
Im Fall, dass wir wach werden
Die Musik dabei
Wo ist der Gegner?
Übrigens, die Shotgun soll richtig OP sein, ne?
Die Shotgun mit Brandmunition soll richtig OP sein, hab ich gelesen
Echt?
Die spawnen bestimmt jetzt hier
Mal gucken, wie der Sound ist
Guck, da ist schon einer, da ist einer
Sample Name, was fuckt du jetzt ab?
Meinst du Shotgun?
Oh, ich glaub der Sound
Alter
Ich glaub es nicht
Der PC-Port ist so abgefuckt, ey
Guck dich das mal an
Also selten sowas Abgefucktes gesehen
Das Game crasht laufend
Äh, Mr. Milchmann
Ne, seit 5 Minuten oder so
Dann müssen wir jetzt besonders leise reden
Weil das Game ja gerne die Mikrofonsettings umstellt
Swift Rage
Also das hab ich noch nie erlebt
Dass ein Game wirklich
So oft
Und so unberechenbar abkackt
Da war Battle Royale
Und Battlefield 1
Äh, sorry
Battlefield 4 bei Release
Nix dagegen
Also mir fällt jetzt nichts ein
Was so instabil war in letzter Zeit
Wie, äh, COD
Also wie World War 2 hier
Was wie, was ist Remote?
Remote ist ne Fernbedienung
Oder was meinste, hä?
What?
Also ich sag ja, wenn das Game
Nicht besser läuft
Dann kauf ich mir das garantiert nicht
Ich seh's ja nicht anders, ey
Also ich sag ja, wenn das Game nicht besser läuft, dann kauf ich mir das garantiert nicht
Ich seh's ja nicht ein, dass, dass das alle, alle
Zweimal in der Runde
Abscheißt
Silent Pain sagt
Bei mir schützt es nie ab, aber Mikro
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, was
Nerviger ist
Da ist auch Schneiber
Am Start hier
Oh
Und wisst ihr, was ich ganz
Was ich wirklich schlimm finde?
Was ich richtig schlimm finde, ist, dass es
Keine Fingerzeige gibt
So was macht man nur, wenn man was verstecken will
So was macht man nicht einfach so
Das macht man nur, wenn man etwas verstecken will
Wenn man, wenn man will, das die Leute
Irgendwas nicht sehen
Wenn man quasi so tun will, als gibt's gute Verbindung
Aber gibt es nicht
Oder so
Pfeilnempfer drauf
Nice
Und da hinten ist ein Gegner
Und den flanken wir jetzt
Flankerino
Achtung, den schneiden wir jetzt.
Komm her.
Oh, fuck.
Ist das jetzt eigentlich P2P?
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Angeblich, angeblich nicht.
Aber ich glaube denen nichts,
weil es gab bei Call of Duty Ghosts ja auch
Dedicated Servers on all Platforms, ne?
Und gab es bis zum Schluss nicht.
Also ich glaube denen nichts in der Richtung.
Ich glaube denen gar nichts.
Also für mich fühlt sich das nicht so an.
Oh, ich habe auf Reddit schon gelesen,
dass Leute Host Migrations hatten.
Was komplett dagegen spricht,
dass es eigene Server sind.
Das ist ein Gegner.
Diese alle versuchen mich out zu strafen, ey.
Kack, nups.
Wreckt.
Gett schreckt.
Gett noch mehr schreckt.
Tyrannosaurus schreckt.
Oh, was haben wir denn hier?
Was ist das?
Oh.
Okay, der Türwart hat keine Ahnung,
wie man gerade ausschießt.
Was ist das hier?
Ah, das ist die Bombe.
Oh, nice.
Oh, oh, oh.
Kann man Gas geben mit dem...
Oh, ich will die bashen.
Ich will die bashen.
Bam.
Au.
Eigentlich kann ich hier einfach stehen bleiben
und in eine Richtung...
Oh, hier kann man sich...
Ich will mich verstecken
und dann Artillerie drauflegen.
Bam.
Jetzt werden sie geschreckt.
Guck, erster ist schon weg.
Krach in your face, Alter.
Oh, was ist das?
In your face.
Noch mehr in your face.
Richtig gebasht.
Okay, typische Call of Duty-Map-Ende.
Man weiß einfach nicht,
warum die Map hier zu Ende ist
und warum man da sowas reinstellen sollte.
Spray and Pray.
Das ist ja...
Das ist das größte Spray and Pray-Game
von allen bisher.
Ich stelle mich mal wieder an meine...
Spray and Pray.
Spray and Pray ist tot.
Das ist echt...
Okay, ähm, jetzt...
Ich lese mal ein Chat.
Warte mal.
Ähm...
Was?
W, W, P, D, D.
Oh, das war eine lange Nachricht.
Wenn ich meinen PC starte,
dann geht es direkt ins...
Ins Bios?
Okay.
Und da macht es so ein komisches,
regelmäßiges Geräusch.
So als würde die Festplatte starten wollen,
schafft es aber nicht.
Kann das am Lüfter liegen oder was?
Letztens war meine Festplatte auch schon kaputt.
Die habe ich gewechselt.
Jetzt ging es wieder.
Aber diesmal ist das Geräusch anders
als bei der Festplatte.
Ähm...
Denn die Festplatte startet...
Also direkt ins Bios liegt ja in der Regel daran,
dass er nicht findet,
von was er booten kann.
Zumindest machen das viele Rechner.
Was damit zusammenpassen wird,
dass seine Festplatte im Arsch ist.
Oder zumindest, wenn du sagst,
es läuft an,
dass das...
Ich sehe Probleme mit der Stromversorgung.
Keine Ahnung, es hört sich ja so an,
als würde der Motor nicht richtig anlaufen.
Aber da kann man Remod nichts dagegen sagen.
Ich würde es einfach mal
an einen anderen Stecker stöpseln.
Mit anderen Stromkabeln dran machen.
Am besten von einer anderen,
anderen Leitung vom Netzteil.
Ähm...
Den SATA-Port mal wechseln.
Im Zweifelsfall...
Einfach mal in den SATA-Stecker pusten.
Das geht immer.
Ging schon bei Super Nintendo Kart.
Wutsch.
Äh...
Wann geht es weiter?
Nein, das bringt nichts,
den Stecker zu pusten.
Aber den Stromstecker kannst du mal wechseln.
Und SATA-Kabel vielleicht.
Einen anderen SATA-Port.
Und wenn das nichts hilft,
würde ich mal versuchen,
von einer Live-CD zu booten.
Beziehungsweise von einem Live-USB-Stick.
Und zu gucken,
ob er die Platte erkennt.
Und so.
Also, das ist...
Das kann man...
Das kann man als Remote wirklich schwer was dazu sagen.
Also, Silent Pain,
der Quickscope-Faktor in dem Spiel,
ist relativ hoch.
Vor allem, wenn man diesen...
Objective-Modus spielt.
Da kann man sich nämlich den Arsch absnipen,
an der einen Stelle,
wo man die Brücke bauen muss.
Aber richtig den Arsch absnipen.
Auf beiden Seiten.
Das ist der Traum für alle...
Für alle krassen Sniper.
Für alle, die gerne im Face-Clan wären,
es einfach nicht packen.
Für die ist das das Beste.
Ansonsten...
Würde ich sagen,
aktuell, so balance-technisch,
was übelst gut ist,
ist Spray'n'Pray aus der Hüfte mit SMG's.
Hat man gerade gesehen.
Vor allem, weil man in dem Spiel schön
AD-AD strafen kann.
Fast so schön, wie in Overwatch.
Ansonsten...
Was halt mega OP ist,
ist die Shotgun zurzeit.
Shotgun mit dieser Brandmunition drinne.
Was richtig kacke sein muss,
ist die doppelläufige Shotgun.
Hab ich aber nur gelesen,
hab ich schon ausprobiert.
Wir probier...
Ich mach mir gleich mal
eine klasse Shotgun mit Brandmunition.
Das gucken wir uns gleich mal an.
Ja frag den Nilshorn,
der kennt sich aus mit sowas.
Wo ich ihn gerade sehe.
So, machen wir jetzt...
Jetzt erst mal den Schalldämpfer dran.
Hi.
Irgendwie sieht das Model übelst scheiße aus.
Das sieht mega scheiße aus.
Was ist hier?
Flanker-Action.
Krasses Flanker-Action.
Die kommen jetzt hier links klar.
Der denkt, ich laufe links.
Guck, der denkt, ich laufe links.
Den haben wir jetzt aber outplayed.
Gebadet haben wir den.
Gebadet.
Kommt in die Ecke gejumpt.
Hat er seine Scav-Maus angeschlossen, ne?
Der Sound ist auch ein bisschen unberechenbar.
Man kann nämlich, obwohl...
Also man sieht die Gegner...
Also ne, die Teammates sind hinter einem,
aber trotzdem
hört es sich so an,
als sind die vor einem und sowas.
Ganz, ganz komisch.
Jetzt hör ich rechts was.
Keine Ahnung, ob wirklich rechts was ist.
Okay, rechts ist was.
Ähm...
NA-Nade.
Spray and Pray.
Guckt euch das mal an,
wie krass die Waffen aus der Hüfte sind.
Ich schieße jetzt nur aus der Hüfte.
Ich muss mir das angucken,
wie OP,
wie OP Spray and Pray aus der Hüfte ist.
Black Desert ist im Sale.
Sollte man sich das gönnen?
Klar.
Wenn man MMOs mag
und vor allem MMOs,
die nicht so dieses übliche Raid-Endgame haben.
Ey, das ist so OP.
Das ist nicht normal.
Da komme ich mit meiner Waffe
nicht hin über die Range.
Die flanken wir jetzt.
Oh, fuck.
Fuck.
Zu viel Spray and Pray.
Aber das Ding ist übelst gut.
Warum gestrapet?
Ah, diesmal läuft es ja ganz toll.
Ey, du bist immer noch hinten.
TF.
Jetzt kann er nicht mal hier sein,
wenn die Leute spawnen.
Also, ich muss sagen,
dass das Spray and Pray aus der Hüfte
ist,
aber es ist nicht so,
dass die Leute spawnen.
Also, ich muss sagen,
dass das Spray and Pray aus der Hüfte
ist,
aber es ist nicht so,
dass die Leute spawnen.
Also, ich muss sagen,
dass das Spray and Pray aus der Hüfte
ist,
aber es ist nicht so,
dass die Leute spawnen.
Also, ich muss sagen,
dass das Spray and Pray нашем
Spiel auch nicht so leicht
oder richtig ist.
Es machtcheutterschauder.
Es machtschauder-Schauderschauder.
Aber im Endeffekt ist es
auch k пятankrass.
Ich hab keiner Ahnung von wo die
kommen.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Was?
Oh, ooh, oh, oh, oh,
ja das stimmt.
Der, das, der Schalldämpfer
machts,
machts ziemlich,
ziemlich schwach über Range.
Aber ich will das jetzt
mal ausprobieren.
Wir mussten es ja
mal ein bisschen testen,
dafür ist ja so eine Beta
auch da.
Einfach mal gucken
Skillnade.
Oder auch nicht.
Oh, der ist tot.
Wollen wir jetzt rüber pushen.
Guckt euch mal das aus der Hüfte an.
Ist doch krass.
Aber der Schalldämpfer ist wirklich kacke.
Der War-Modus ist cool.
Das einzige Problem, was ich mit dem War-Modus habe, ist,
dass ich finde, es sind fast ein bisschen zu viele Spieler für die Map-Größe.
Okay, jetzt hören wir mal mit der reinen Hüft-Spray-and-Play-Geschichte auf.
Wie sie alle ihre krassen Face-Moves machen.
Was ist das?
Oh, meine Granate war es wirklich.
Wollt.
Ich charge da jetzt durch.
Ha, ha, ha.
Rekt.
Moment, wo sind die alle hin?
Ich habe jetzt richtig geile Flank gemacht, ne?
Alles weg.
Wie, die sind alle tot?
Voll durchgeflankt.
Aber die kommen jetzt gleich.
Mhm.
Was?
Der Sound, wenn man einen killt, das gefällt mir sogar ganz gut.
Das fühlt sich so an, als würde was passieren.
Ah, ich habe ja...
...killstreaks.
Gucken, wo der herkommt.
Achtung, da oben kommt gleich noch einer.
Den lauern wir jetzt hier mal auf, so.
Richtig schön Camp-Act.
Bisschen Head-Klitschen noch.
Bisschen Head-Klitschen.
Head-Klitsch is real.
Spaltet sie einfach.
Kommt aber nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo ist der Typ hin?
Wo ist er?
Da gehen wir nicht durch, das ist viel zu lang.
Die meisten stehen einfach nur rum.
Was ist mit denen los?
Durchchargen, durchchargen.
Da kennen wir nix.
Sniper.
Oh, der wird gebasht.
Ich will den...
Oh, fuck.
Ich wollte...
Ah, Mann.
Ups.
Ich bin rausgetappt.
Ich wollte im Nahkampf bashen.
Ich habe die falsche Taste gedrückt.
Ich habe F gedrückt aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Was ist im Nahkampf nochmal gewesen?
Ach, V.
Oh.
Und wenn man die falsche Taste drückt, ne?
V, das ist ja eine richtige Kacke.
Ich muss Nahkampf wieder auf rechte Maustaste machen.
Einzig sinnvolle.
Schöner Call of Duty-Tod.
Den Rücken geschossen.
Ich komme jetzt gleich von hier vorne.
Null.
Perfekt.
Die Maps finde ich ganz gut bis jetzt, muss ich sagen.
Die Maps finde ich wirklich ganz gut.
Nicht drei Milliarden Wege, aber genug.
So.
Ähm.
Mal Chat lesen.
Welche CPU hast du?
Ich habe aktuell noch ne...
Nicht das?
Ne.
Ähm.
Ich habe aktuell noch nen Xeon V...
Ne.
Ein Xeon 1230 V3.
Sehr griffiger Name, ne?
Danke für die ganzen Follows.
Ich höre es im Hintergrund bimmeln.
Ja, Skip.
Mir interessiert denn das?
So, was können wir nochmal...
Was können wir nochmal ausrüsten?
Wir machen uns jetzt wirklich mal so ne OP.
Gibt es eigentlich unterschiedliche Waffen zwischen...
Zwischen, sagen wir, Infanterie und...
Ne, nicht wirklich, ne?
Ne.
Wir machen uns dann...
Wir machen uns danach mal ne OP...
Ne OP-Klasse mit Shotgun.
Probieren wir das mal aus, ob das wirklich so OP ist.
Also.
Die...
Als wir vorgestern...
Diesen Objective-Modus gespielt haben,
da war natürlich Shotgun auf den engen Gebieten total OP.
Also maßlos OP.
Will gleich ne Map.
Ähm.
Hallo, Leute.
Kommt ins Game.
Ich muss...
Moment, ich muss...
Ah, wichtig.
Controls.
Keep innings.
Nahkampf.
Maus 4.
Das ist auch wieder sowas, was 100 pro dem Konsolenport geschuldet ist,
dass man nicht zwei Tasten einfach zuweisen kann.
Weil sau viele Games hatten früher und auch immer noch,
ähm, doppelt...
Also du konntest quasi Haupttaste festlegen und Alternative.
Uh!
Oh!
Was jetzt nicht mehr funktioniert.
Mal gucken, da flankt uns was.
Lull!
Outplayed!
Da rechts war was, rechts war was.
Der wird jetzt gebasht, rechts.
Dirty baited.
Oh, ist hier was?
Ich hab den...
Achso, es ist gar kein Gegner in Game.
Also kaum Gegner drinne.
Das würde es natürlich erklären,
dass wir nix sehen an Gegner,
wenn hier irgendwie nix in dem Game drinne ist.
Sagt aber.
Ich höre was.
Gott, das sackt es.
Off-Range mit dem Schall...
Wow.
Ich höre da was.
Ach, das sind jetzt meine Teammates.
What?
Was war das denn?
Ach, geschnallt.
So, jetzt ist das Game wenigstens voll.
Das Strayf-Movement ist auch komisch.
Erinnert mich ein bisschen an Bad Company.
Ja.
Also, wenn man dieses Rennstrayfen...
Das ist ein bisschen wie in Bad Company.
Ich zeige es euch mal.
Was ich meine.
Alter.
Wenn du so geradeaus rennst,
dann links und rechts strayfst,
dann rennst du weiter geradeaus,
aber so...
Was ist da oben?
Spray and pray.
Next.
Hat er mich gesehen oder nicht?
Das ist so OP,
das aus der Hüfte sprayen.
Der denkt jetzt, er kann mich da oben drinnen ownen, ha?
Komm her.
Warum ist der Typ nicht abgehauen?
Warum ist der Typ nicht von meiner Granate weggerannt gerade?
Ist er irgendwie total im Scheu oder was?
Und, was ich komisch finde,
diese, diese, diese Holo-Visiere.
Irgendwie verbinde ich den Zweiten Weltkrieg
nicht mit Holo-Visieren, so.
Oder?
Wie sieht es bei euch aus?
Meint ihr, euer Opa hat einen Holo-Visier?
Nein.
Mein Opa hatte einen Holo-Visier.
Ah.
Läuft er.
Ich weiß echt noch nicht,
was ich von dem, von dem Game halten soll.
Das, also so Gun-technisch und sowas,
macht das, macht das wirklich Spaß.
Aber, eh, wie so das,
der Spielfluss ist irgendwie komisch.
Ich kann das noch nicht so richtig in Worte fassen.
Hallo?
Wie viele Headshots halten die aus?
Haben wir?
Ah.
Wat, wat?
Und halt die typischen Call of Duty Tote, dass man immer von hinten stirbt.
Ich lese gleich, ich lese gleich die Sachen im Chat.
Ein bisschen auf das Game konzentrieren.
Was hat mich da jetzt so getroffen?
Der rennt mir bestimmt hinterher.
Ist klar.
Pistolen hab ich doch gar nicht ausprobiert.
Warum bin ich erster?
Mit meinen krassen 11 zu 7 Stats.
Wahnsinn.
Den hinteren Teil der Map verwendet irgendwie gar keiner, so richtig hab ich das Gefühl.
Den holen wir uns.
Der wird gebasht.
Das ist OP, das ist das hüftige Spray, ey, krasse Scheiße.
Mal hören.
Hier ist nix.
Oh, Bombe.
Bleib mal hier drinnen.
Den hat man gehört.
Also das finde ich gut.
Ei.
Alter.
Verrecken ey.
Das finde ich gut, dass man die Gegner mittlerweile wieder ordentlich hört.
Und dass man wieder ordentlich Flank-Action machen kann.
Die müssen doch jetzt hier hinten was spawen.
Machen sie aber nicht.
Haben sie keinen Bock.
Flanken wir mal außen rechts.
Wenn wir jetzt hier weiter gehen müssen, werden wir direkt durch den ganzen Hof durch.
Was ziemlich sagt.
Wir warten jetzt mal, ob einer kommt.
Ich höre was von...
Also das Orten ist komisch, ne?
Der Typ da oben, da hatte ich angehört, als kommt er von da.
Ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
Ganz, ganz...
Oh, wow, wow.
Ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
Jetzt sind die FPS ganz okay.
Seitdem ich ein bisschen Grafik runtergestellt habe heute Morgen.
Aber es ist immer noch nicht angemessen.
Ich bin für eine 1080 DI, finde ich.
Da kann ich auf Long Range nicht contesten mit meiner...
Weg hier, weg hier.
Okay, wo spawnt hier was?
Oh, die werden aber direkt von der Artillerie.
Die Leute werden hier gespawnt.
Wow, perfekt.
Super.
Was habe ich denn da eigentlich?
Ah, das ist das...
Der UAV.
Ich kann hier nicht raus.
Kriege ich auf den Sack.
Okay, gehen wir jetzt mal hier links hoch.
Alles voll, alles voll, ey.
Oh, fuck, jetzt sehen sie, dass ich da bin.
Läuft das Spiel auf DirectX 12?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich denke nicht, dass es auf DirectX 12 läuft.
Was auch ein bisschen merkwürdig wäre, wenn das auf der X...
Na gut.
Ne, glaube ich nicht.
Ich glaube nicht.
Zumal einfach nur DirectX 12, ohne dass man weiß, wie es geht, bringt dir ja auch jetzt nichts, ne?
Ich meine, nur wenn du eine andere Technologie verwendest, mit der du potenziell quasi mehr rausholen könntest
und du nicht weißt, wie du die benutzt, kann dein Spiel trotzdem schlechter laufen als mit der alten.
Das Gespräch ist bei Battlefield 1 mindestens genauso krass.
Ja, das war auch ein Grund, warum ich keinen Bock auf Battlefield 1 hatte.
Also, was ich ganz merkwürdig fand in Battlefield 1, waren die einen Waffen, die quasi...
quasi...
genauer geworden sind, umso mehr du sprayst.
Wo ich mir gedacht habe, hä?
Das habe ich ja in noch keinem Game gesehen.
Und das andere waren die Assault Rifles, die quasi nicht dahin geschossen haben, wo du hingezielt hast.
Also quasi wie Suppression in Battlefield 3, bloß eingebaut in die Waffe.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, ne Leute, das kann ich mir in Battlefield...
Das kann ich mir nicht geben.
Deswegen habe ich mir Battlefield 1 auch nicht gekauft.
So, wir...
Wir wollten uns eine OP...
OP-Shotgun-Klasse machen.
OP-Shotgun-Klasse.
Panzerschreck!
Was von den...
Wo kann man eigentlich...
Ich meine, ich habe mich mit OP-Sachen in dem Game noch nicht beschäftigt.
Äh, welche Waffe hat denn...
Oder wo kann man denn diese Brandmunition auswählen?
Ich muss mir das jetzt mal angucken, ob das wirklich so OP ist.
Weiß das jemand, welche Shotgun das ist und was man dafür auswählen muss?
Ich muss jetzt auch mal OP-Kombination testen.
Oh, jetzt ist es...
Jetzt wird die Shotgun...
Panzerklasse war das?
Okay.
Also die hier, oder was?
Ist das Brandmunition?
Ja!
Ah!
Oh, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Lol!
Was ist das?
Okay, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen sehr weit.
Wir müssen jetzt mal OP-Zeug ausprobieren.
Wir flanken da jetzt rein.
Was ist das für eine Range mit der Shotgun?
What the fuck?
Und warum liegt der Typ da rum?
WTF?
Was ist das?
What the fuck ist das?
Warum hat das so eine große Range?
Ich würde mich gerne mal recken.
Ah, man hat nur vier.
Okay, das geht ja eigentlich.
Ich...
Komm her.
Shotgun, Alter.
Shotgun.
Guck dir das mal an.
Ich renne übrigens grad einfach sinnlos durch, ne?
Jetzt kommt...
Pass auf, die kriegen jetzt die Bombe auf den Kopf.
Kann man Gas geben?
Bam!
Schreckt.
Recon flight concluded.
Wir warten jetzt hier einfach.
Wir warten jetzt hier, bis der Typ langkommt und dann wird er gebasht.
Deck.
Shotgun.
Wie OP ist denn das Ding, ey?
Nicht OP. Balanced. Balanced. Balanced.
Richtig balanced.
Äh, da.
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist jetzt ein guter...
...guter Spot war für...
Oh, da ist einer.
Hier kann ich nicht rüberrennen mit Shotgun.
Zack. Achtung.
Ui.
Tyrannosaurus.
Rekt war das wieder.
Rekt.
Alter, die Shotgun. Was ist das?
Ist es denen hier ernst, ja?
Also, als Ernst,
die Shotgun ist schon echt massiv OP.
Ich lese gleich die Frage.
Äh,
Hufferdilox.
Was hältst du von den Menüs im Spiel? Kacke.
Einfach kacke.
Man hat die Menüs für den Controller genommen
und Tasten von der Tastatur dran geschrieben.
Fertig.
Du denkst doch nicht, dass du mich hier outscuff
playen kannst.
Shotgun. Ich packe es nicht, ey.
Lernen die eigentlich nicht raus,
dass diese Klassen in jedem Game
geflamed werden ohne Ende
und man die vielleicht nicht mal so OP machen sollte?
Und man die vielleicht nicht mal so OP machen sollte?
Vor allem, wenn man standardmäßig noch diese Brandmunition hat.
Das ist richtig hart.
Oben ist einer. Achtung, go, go.
Kann man da rein? Oh, geil!
Das finde ich gut. Das finde ich gut, wenn's...
Wenn's da so
Flankwege gibt. Das finde ich geil.
Wo man ein bisschen mit ein bisschen Movement
Action dann auch durch kann.
Ja, so Peterschiff, ey.
Outplayed, outplayed, outplayed.
Rekt!
Das muss ich mir speichern.
Irgendwie freut mich sowas.
900 IQ.
Oh, wow, wow, wow.
Komm her.
Ich hör euch allerdings. Kommt her.
Kommt her.
Hä? Wieso?
What? Nein!
Ver-aimed!
22-5, ey.
Ein wenig OP.
Nur ein bisschen OP, ja. Nicht viel.
Ganz klein wenig.
Wo geht's denn hier lang?
Moment, war da was von hinten?
Rekt.
Moment, war da ein Gegner hinter mir?
Ey, wie krass OP, das ist der Wahnsinn.
Wie der wieder schreit.
Komm her.
Ich hör dich da rechts.
Ich hör dich, ich hör dich.
Ich sollte vielleicht mal meine Killstreaks einsetzen.
Fällt mir gerade ein.
Mach ich jetzt, wa?
Auf, spawn.
Oh ja.
In your face.
Äh, ähm, ähm.
Äh, ja. Besser.
Beste Bob aller Zeiten.
Ähm, ähm.
Der Kaboom hat angerufen,
gerade auf dem Handy.
Ich muss weg.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung. Kommt her, kommt her.
Eine Brandmunition.
Oh, ne.
Oh.
Nach der Runde muss ich mich mal kurz muten.
Ich schreibe mal.
Äh, äh, ne, ne. Ich schreibe nach der Runde.
Lass doch mal kurz.
Komm her, komm her, komm her.
Ich will nicht.
Achtung.
Ja, oh. Der wird jetzt outplayed, der Typ.
Guck, passt doch mal auf, ja.
Oder auch nicht.
Ich dachte, wir machen jetzt die Dinger mit mehr Range rein, dann werden sie gebasht.
Glotz.
Ich habe jetzt die Killcam nicht anguckt. War ich das?
War ich das in der Killcam?
Ich habe gerade, äh, Message geschrieben.
Und was zum Teufel, nochmal Chat.
Einfach mal ein bisschen Krach machen, dann würden wir jetzt chatten.
Ey, wo ist Chat?
Äh, Moment, ich wusste nicht, was war denn jetzt Settings?
Ich weiß es in der Killcam, guys.
Was hier mit den Grafik-Settings läuft, mit 100 plus.
Okay, jetzt gucke ich mir das mal an.
Keylogger ist wahrscheinlich auch in der UL drin, ne?
Hoffe ich mal.
Jetzt werde ich enttäuscht.
Null.
Ähm, ich mach das eh mit Linux auf, die ganzen ULs, also, who cares.
Ähm, Controls.
Was war denn jetzt nochmal Chat?
Chat.
Die Menüs.
Die Menüs, also die Menüs.
Chat.
Fuck.
T.
T war Chat, okay.
Warum sollte ich meine Screen Refresh Rate auf 119,98 Hertz stellen?
Das ist ganz schön, ganz schön fail.
Übrigens, das Game hängt bei mir gerade.
Game?
Hallo?
So, nehmen wir mal.
Nehmen wir mal wieder was nochmal.
Nehmen wir mal nochmal, spielen wir jetzt mal mit, mit Sturmgewehr.
Bayonett-Shot.
Oh, das ist, das ist gar nicht wie in Battlefield.
Warum, warum wimmelt das jetzt?
Das Game, ey.
Sehr stabil.
Sehr stabiles Game.
Press F.
Lasst uns mal Respect Payen.
Das ist so fail.
Also, gute Werbung für das Game ist es nicht, weil eine richtige Beta kann es ja nicht sein.
Der Release ist noch nicht, der ist ja quasi um die Ecke, um aus dieser Beta irgendwie großartige
Schlüsse zu ziehen, ist es eigentlich viel zu kurz, das heißt, es ist so eine typische
Promotion-Beta-Demo, Schrägstrich-Demo, dafür läuft es schlecht.
Ich habe heute Morgen extra nochmal, ähm, Nvidia-Driver aktualisiert und es war sogar
im Installationsmenü vom Nvidia-Driver.
Werbung für das neue Call of Duty, also das heißt, ich gehe mal davon aus, dass sie sogar
das ein bisschen was optimiert haben.
Ja, coole, ganz bestimmt.
Dass der Finn eine Facecam hat, das wundert mich eh, der wollte sowas doch auch nie.
Also man hat ihn ja schon öfters gesehen als mich.
Ich sieht mir nur, mich hat man ja zwar auch schon in manchen Videos so ansatzweise gesehen
oder irgendwo im Hintergrund rumstehen sehen, aber der Finn, der wollte ja eigentlich auch
nie, äh, nie, nie Facecam.
Deswegen wundert es mich, dass der jetzt auch nicht Facecam hat.
Oh, Start ist.
War jetzt cool, oder?
Team Deathmatch.
Rachen, rachen, Alter, rachen.
Headglitchen.
Headglitch, wichtigste.
Wichtigste von allen Headglitch.
Muss real sein.
Ohne Headglitch geht nix.
Das Wichtigste.
Lasst euch das mal gesagt sein.
Wenn irgendwie einer sagt, Headglitch ist Noob-Scheiße, stimmt nicht.
Headglitch ist...
Wisst ihr, ich hab nicht ge-Headglitcht und schon bin ich kaputt.
Hätte ich ge-Headglitcht, hätte ich gewonnen.
So dumm das jetzt klingt, das stimmt sogar.
Der Waffe muss man ein bisschen aimen.
Was?
Fuck, da war doch eben noch nix.
Ne, ne, ich switch jetzt lieber wieder auf Shotgun.
Der Typ, guck mal, der Typ hier, der hört sich bei mir an, als er noch hinter mir war,
als ist er neben mir oder vor mir.
Ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
Oh, jetzt haben wir...
Wir kriegen gerade so mega auf den Sack.
So, weil wir so sehr auf den Sack kriegen, bleibt mir leider nix anderes übrig, wie Shotgun zu spielen.
Flanken wir mal außen rum.
Guck, der macht's richtig, der Headglitcht.
Dann, dann gewinnt man auch.
Was war denn das jetzt?
War das die Waffe 100 oder die Waffe 28 oder was war das?
Au.
Achtung, der rennt mir jetzt hinterher, der Typ.
Type 100 war das.
Okay, das probieren wir jetzt.
Mach mal aus, die hab ich doch hier ausgerüstet.
Die testen wir jetzt auch mal.
Wir kriegen zwar gerade absolut krass auf den Sack.
Ist das...
Das sei UAV, hä?
Das ist nix, wo man wo rausgeschossen wird.
Okay, die geht ab.
Also die Waffen fühlen sich gut an.
Das haben sie gut...
Also das haben sie richtig hingekriegt.
Okay, Damage macht der nicht wirklich.
Und mit Suppressor gar nicht.
Aber den mal wieder runter.
Aber das Ding macht auch nicht viel...
Au.
Was war denn das?
Ah, STG.
Wir spielen jetzt mal für die Typ 100.
Wobei ich sagen muss, wir müssen auch mal ein anderes Spielmode spielen.
Team Deathmatch hängt mir ein bisschen zum Hals raus.
So auf zwei Maps quasi oder auf drei.
Oh.
Der kommt hier, klar jetzt.
Alter, was ist denn hier los?
Kriegen wir gerade richtig auf den Sack.
Die Runden davor übelst gewockt.
Und jetzt...
In your face.
Gut, die Runde direkt davor war...
Shotgun-Action.
Wie findest du das Spiel bis jetzt?
Ich bin...
Ich hab echt meine Schwierigkeiten dazu, was zu sagen.
Also, ähm...
Ich...
Das Setting gefällt mir.
Die Maps finde ich bis jetzt auch nicht schlecht.
Ne, da kann ich mit meiner SMG nicht drauf einlassen.
Das Waffen-Handling und so, das gefällt mir auch ganz gut.
Aber irgendwie...
Und ich kann es noch nicht näher in Wort fahren.
Der Spielfluss ist komisch.
Der Spielfluss ist irgendwie komisch.
Ich weiß nicht.
Man...
Ich meine, es war schon immer schwierig zu predikten, so in Call of Duty, in TDR, wo Gegner herkommen.
Aber...
Es ist...
Es ist merkwürdig.
Schwierig gerade.
Also ich kann es noch nicht so richtig einschätzen.
Was natürlich ganz indiskutabel ist, ist auf dem PC einmal Performance, Menüs und...
Was war es da noch, wo ich mich eben drüber aufgedrückt habe?
Ähm...
Ja, das ist...
Ja, Sibaro, so ist das.
Sibaro, du verpasst nichts.
Du verpasst gerade, dass ich übelst auf den Sack lege.
Runden davor alles gerockt und jetzt einfach nur...
Das ist Maul.
Übrigens, wir verlieren die Runde gerade, weil ich satt bin.
Was geht hier gerade ab?
Wow.
Die muss ich auch mal ausprobieren danach.
Der kommt jetzt rechts.
Warum?
Ich darf nicht immer rechts rennen.
Rechts ist so Mid-Range, Long-Range Waffen.
Ich muss eigentlich eher links unten hier so...
Flanken.
Ah, hier in die Mitte ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Hier langstelzen.
Jetzt gehen wir oben lang.
Kill geleached.
What?
Darf ich auch nochmal meine Kills irgendwie bekommen?
Oh, fuck.
Jetzt weiß er, wo ich bin.
Wo ist der Typ?
Komm her.
Bombe.
Oh.
Ich dachte, er würde mich outplayen.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich schon eine Bombe?
Achtung, wir campen jetzt uns mal hier einen ab.
Wir holen ihn.
Achtung.
1,20.
Gebäscht.
Perfekt.
Der ist direkt neben mir.
Ich habe hier was gehört gerade.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Bam.
Perfekt.
Artillery.
Erst mal warten, bis wir gereckt sind.
Ich höre, glaube ich, was von hinten.
Ah, super.
Also, man muss sagen, man hört den Gegner wirklich viel besser, als in den Teilen vorher.
Jetzt sind wir am Chat losgegangen.
Recon?
Gleich mal Artillery hinterher.
Oh, Bashing.
Bashing.
Bam.
Ich renne da jetzt aber nicht rein.
Das wäre jetzt richtig NA-Play, in meine eigene Artillery zu rennen.
Nicht NA-Play.
Das wäre nicht NA-Play, wäre das.
Was?
Moment.
Wo kam...
Ach, der stand da in der Ecke.
Weil, ich wollte gerade sagen, ich habe da noch lange geguckt.
Alter, der Chat.
Hilfe.
Weep Invasion.
Victory.
Äh.
Ich glaube, das Shotgun-Gameplay lade ich nachher mal hoch.
So einfach, dass man mal sieht, wie Balance wieder die Shotgun ist.
Wir machen uns jetzt noch eine eigene OP-Shotgun.
Die Shotgun-Klasse.
Mehr 360s?
Ich werde es probieren.
Aber kann man 360s mit Assault-Rifles oder SMGs machen?
Das geht eigentlich nicht.
360s kann man eigentlich...
Also die richtigen 360s, ja?
Also die, die quasi...
Also nicht die ehrenlosen 360s.
Die kann man eigentlich nur mit einer Bolt-Action-Sniper machen.
Wir machen uns eine Sniper-Klasse.
Ganz, ganz wichtig.
Ja.
Lass mich raus.
Ich muss Klasse ausrüsten hier.
Go, go.
Ähm.
Sniper.
Hü.
Mit Rang 29.
Okay, nehmen wir das Ding.
Können da eh nichts dran machen.
Nice.
So, Spiel jetzt.
Jetzt wird gesniped.
Easy win.
Ganz leichter Spam im Chat.
Me weep, me spam.
Mod Bucker if ban.
Debated.
So, jetzt wird geschniped.
Jetzt wird geschniped.
Ich sag's euch.
Ich hab meine Sensitivity überhaupt nicht.
Guckt mal.
Ich hab hier.
Einmal übers Mauspad.
Gerade mal so.
Das geht nicht.
Mit der Sensitivity kann ich keine 360s machen.
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Hardscroll.
Wie die letzten Kack-Noobs.
Hardscroll-Noobs.
Die Map ist, glaube ich, für Sniper eh generell nicht so wahnsinnig geeignet.
Hardscroll.
Moment.
Bolt-Action.
Kann das sein, dass das gar keine Bolt-Action ist, die ich hier hab?
Dann damit geht das schon mal gar nicht.
Wollte gerade sagen, weil warum sterben die nicht, wenn ich draufschieße?
Moment.
Das ist...
Ach, das ist eine Auto...
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Also mit Auto-Sniper geht das nicht.
Dann spielen wir lieber Typ 100 frei.
Auto-Sniper.
Das ist ja halt für die allergrößten Kack-Noobs.
Guckt es euch mal an, ey.
Auto-Sniper.
Null.
Nee, nee.
Mit Auto-Sniper geht das nicht.
Recon Airbomb.
Searching for targets.
Guckt euch das mal an, ey.
Auto-Sniper.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Auto-Sniper nicht.
Wir switchen jetzt auf Typ 100.
Auto-Sniper.
Ah.
Jetzt müssen wir erstmal die Runde carryen wieder.
Carry pants.
Hallo?
Wo sind die Gegner?
Recon Airbomb.
Ah, da, da.
Die Gegner.
Gegner bashen.
Die Gegner kriegen gerade so...
So auf den Sack.
Dass da nicht viel geht.
Hinter uns, hinter uns.
Hä?
Moment.
Oh, Flank, Flank-Action.
Jetzt hat der natürlich die krasse Head-Clich-Position.
Hier ist nix.
Oh.
Jetzt wollte er mich outplayen.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Mein Team macht die Gegner gerade so schnell kaputt.
Kriegst ja...
Kriegst ja nix ab.
So, jetzt stellen wir uns hier hin und gucken einfach gerade aus.
Easy.
Oh, ich bleib jetzt hier stehen.
Bewegt mich jetzt nicht mehr.
Ich bewegt mich nicht mehr.
Oh, oh, fuck.
Das sind ein bisschen viele.
Flank, Flank, Flank, Flank.
Flank-Marino.
Okay, jetzt kommen sie von hinten.
Ich hab keine Munition mehr.
Äh, Munition.
Gebt mir Waffe.
Keine Waffe mehr.
Boah, super.
Egal, ich bin eh down.
Kann jemand von euch die Copy-Paste-Geschichte mit dem...
Mit dem Balancieren von...
Mit dem Balancieren von den Dosen?
Ich find, das ist die hohe Kunst.
Könnt ihr Dosen balancieren?
Der kommt rechts.
Mein Kill.
Könnt ihr die Dosen...
Macht mal die Dosen.
Alter, bleibst du nicht hängen.
Ich hab nicht nachgelassen.
Ich hab mich halt einfach draufgeschraubt.
Kommt noch was?
Ey, ey, lass mich weg.
Ey, das sind so die typischen Call-of-Duty-Torte.
Bitte.
Nee, nee, nee, Leute.
So geht das nicht.
Die Dosen müssen auf dem Kopf gestapelt werden.
So kann ich das auch.
Ihr müsst die Dosen auf dem Kopf stapeln.
Auf dem Forehead.
Hätt ich meine Kills?
Alles meine Kills.
Aber ich krieg's ja nicht.
Den holen wir jetzt.
Der wird gebasht.
Ich krieg keine Kills.
Das ist die Night.
Und dann verreck ich ihn.
Ja, fast.
Fast Silent-Pain.
Fast.
Schön Head-Klitschen.
Fuck.
W-Wat?
Es gibt kein...
Es gibt kein Nahkampf.
Wir springen dem Gegner mehr entgegen.
Was ich eigentlich ganz gut finde.
Und es gibt ja auch nicht mehr Panic Knife.
Es gibt ja...
Sag mal.
Was?
Ey!
Uah!
Wie ich die wegsprayen kann?
Mit der Typ 100 geht das nicht richtig.
Die beste Spray-Waffe ist diese...
Wie heißt denn das Ding?
Dieses kleine schwarze...
Kleine schwarze SMG.
Das ist die beste Spray-Waffe.
Da kannst du echt über die halbe Map aus der Hüfte sprayen.
Beste.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ich muss weg.
Warum ich?
Das ist für meine Range nicht gut.
Der Face-Peter ist hier.
Das ist das neue Face-Member.
Was meint er?
Ist er real?
Ist er real, Face?
Ich denke schon.
Ich denke, Face-Peter, der wird als nächstes richtig gut starten hier auf YouTube.
Klassen-Quickscope-Montages.
Ich hab ihn gehittert.
Aber ich denke, Face-Peter ist hier der nächste...
Ich hab schon vergessen, wie die ganzen Face-Tube-Minds heißen.
Ich glaub's nicht.
Irgendwie kommst du da ab.
Ich bin mir davon nicht klar.
Was?
BF1 stinkt hart?
Naja.
Ja, eigentlich schon.
Eigentlich schon.
Ich glaub, das ist hier so eine richtige Shotgun-Map.
Das Ding killt ja auch nichts.
Ah, ich hab einen Schalldämpfer drauf.
Deswegen macht das kein Damage.
Ja, ohne Schalldämpfer geht das auch gleich viel besser.
Ja, ohne Schalldämpfer geht das da gleich mal viel besser.
Ah!
Wo ist denn der Typ?
Oh, bashen.
Was?
Oh, gibt's diese Scheiße hier auch wieder?
Da hab ich ja gar keinen Bock drauf auf Claymores.
Claymores, ey.
Also, ich hab immer noch keinen gesehen, der die Pyramide hinkriegt.
Ich bin echt enttäuscht.
Oh, such skill, such skill.
Hier, Face-Peter.
Oh, der war gut, der Face-Peter.
Habt ihr das gesehen? 0,20.
Das kann nur ein Real-Face gewesen sein, weil er Trickshots probiert.
So, was können wir jetzt nochmal anlocken?
Was gibt's hier noch Schönes?
Also, die Waffe suckt.
Ist das hier...
Okay, das ist eine Ball-Action.
Dann nehmen wir das Ding.
Ball-Action.
So, was haben wir ansonsten noch hier Schönes zu bieten?
Typ 100, können wir da jetzt was...
Ah, sehr schön.
Scope, Scope suckt.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Aim down sights, machen wir uns.
Ordentliches Visier drauf.
Was bringt das hier?
Gar nichts, das ist einfach nur...
Einfach nur Obsik, oder?
Oder?
Moment, oder sind das da unten die Perks, quasi?
Hä?
Das sind die Perks?
Ah, okay, verstehe.
Und die Perks sind wahrscheinlich je nach Division anders.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
So, gucken wir mal, wie die Typ 100 ist jetzt mit Visier.
Visier.
Ja, sieht schon besser aus, das Ding.
Siehst du sie?
Fast, fast.
Also, bei mir ist es nicht gerade.
Jetzt wird geflankt.
Mit Schalldämpfer.
Schalldämpfer flank.
Wir rennen jetzt hier drüber, bis Gegner da sind.
Bevor Gegner da sind, sind wir jetzt hier drüber.
Easy.
Oh, das Ding macht überhaupt kein Damage mit Schalldämpfer.
Ich höre hier Gegner rennen.
Rekt!
Ah, ist gesprossen.
Was?
Null.
Das Ding macht mit Schalldämpfer nicht wirklich viel Schaden.
Wo kommen die her?
Der Face Peter ist wieder da.
Okay, okay.
Die ORV?
Den holen wir jetzt, der kommt hier gleich rein.
Oder auch nicht.
Nice.
Der nächste, der kommt jetzt hier.
Oh, fuck.
Aber jetzt gleich mal eine Granate aufkommen.
Die Waffe.
Zwangs muss auch ziemlich gut sein, was ich so auf Reddit gelesen habe.
Bäschen, bäschen.
Kann man mit dem Ding irgendwie Gas geben?
So Predator-mäßig kann man mit dem Ding Gas geben, weiß das jemand?
Weil so ist mir das ein bisschen langsam.
Moin, Kia-Zone.
Oben ist was.
Ich höre was, ich höre was.
Rekt.
Ich höre immer noch was.
Ich weiß jetzt aber nicht, ob das meine Leute sind, oder Gegner sind, die ich höre.
Ah!
Ja, ist klar, voll, voll durch Dauerfeuer durchrennen.
Gar kein Problem, überhaupt kein Problem.
Wo kann man eigentlich Killstreaks anpassen?
Oder geht das nicht?
Ich fänd das geil, wenn das nicht geht.
Geht das vielleicht nicht?
Sind die Killstreaks fest?
Wäre das möglich, dass die Killstreaks fest sind?
Äh, was sagst du zum Netcode?
Ähm...
Moment.
Ich sage zum Netcode, dass ich mir erhofft habe, dass es richtige Server gibt.
Und ich bin mir...
Also, es funktioniert, ja.
Es ist aber kein großer Unterschied zu anderen.
Fuck.
Es ist aber kein großer Unterschied.
Also manche Hitmarker...
Also man kriegt manchmal Hitmarker, obwohl der Hitmarker tot ist.
Man kriegt manchmal Hitmarker, obwohl man den nicht getroffen hat.
Man stirbt um die Ecke.
Angeblich gibt es Server, aber es gibt Leute, die hatten Host-Migrations.
Ähm, an sich...
Es funktioniert ganz okay.
Oh, sieht man ja.
Das funktioniert schon ganz gut.
Ähm...
Spray'n'Pray ist halt saugut wieder.
Mit SMGs.
Also vor allem mit der einen.
Mit der hier nicht unbedingt.
Bombe, ich bleib mal hier drin.
Ich muss weg.
Komm her.
Headlitch, Headlitch.
Hahaha.
Schön ins Gesicht gerannt.
Oh, 16-4.
Das ist eine richtig gute Runde.
Klammer speichert.
Ich hab da was gesehen.
Was?
Immer von der Seite.
Und das links unten ist glaube ich das Netcode-Symbol, wenn es laggt.
Was ist das?
Oh, der Face, Peter.
Mal gucken, wie viel das aushält.
Oder so.
Ich hör hier was.
Die Waffen ohne...
Ich zeig euch das jetzt mal.
Also was ich richtig...
Welche Waffe ich richtig gut finde, ist die hier.
Für Spray'n'Pray aus der Hüfte.
Hab ich die richtige Klasse ausgewählt?
Ne, die da brauche ich nicht.
Oder?
Keine Ahnung.
Irgendwo habe ich das bessere Hüftfeuer ausgewählt.
Das ist richtig OP.
Da kann man über die halbe Map aus der Hüfte schießen.
Guckt euch an.
Warte mal, war das die richtige?
Ich denke mal die hier, ja.
Da kannst du die halbe Map über die Hüfte schießen.
Aus der Hüfte schießen über die halbe Map.
Oh, das ist schlecht.
Jetzt wissen sie, dass ich hier lang laufe.
Guck, guck, guck hier.
Halbe Map gesprayt.
Von hinten?
Was?
Und nachdem man in dem Game AD-AD strafen kann, fast so gut wie in Overwatch,
ist aus der Hüfte schießen auch ziemlich gut.
Ich verstecke mich mal.
Bombe.
Guckt doch, habt ihr es gesehen?
Wie man aus der Hüfte sprayen kann.
Ja gut.
Call of Duty Tote sind immer von der Seite.
Ich höre da was.
YOLO.
Moment, was willst du hier?
Oh, ich habe eine...
Oh, ich habe eine Donation.
Ich habe eine Donation gekriegt.
Ich gucke gleich.
Ich gucke gleich nach der Runde.
Wenn ich es vergessen sollte, spammt mich voll.
Weil sowas darf man ja nicht.
Das gehört sich ja nicht.
Wo ist der Typ hin?
Wie ich ihn nicht gesehen habe.
Moment, ich gucke mal Donation.
Ich kann mich nicht mehr bewegen richtig.
Ich habe, wenn ich nach links und rechts drücke, übelst Input lag.
Okay, jetzt geht es wieder.
Was auch immer.
Oh.
Oh, das Sibaro hat Donated.
Danke, 15 Euro.
Die Beta-Performance am PC ist eher so monkares.
Ja, das stimmt.
Die Performance ist nicht gut.
Fuck.
Wie ich gespawnt bin und gleich mal eine Granate am Kopf kriege.
Stellst du uns hier mal lang?
Nichts.
Ah, ich dachte, der Typ heißt Christian Pfeiffer.
Das wäre mal ein guter Name gewesen.
Ja, die Performance ist nicht sonderlich gut.
Das ist geil.
Wenn man rausgetappt hat, ne?
Wenn ich raustappe aus dem Game und wieder reingehe,
habe ich die ersten 10 Sekunden Input lag.
Ich drücke.
Hört ihr das?
Jetzt geht es wieder.
Das dauert dann so 10, 15 Sekunden, bis man sich überhaupt wieder richtig bewegen kann.
Also der PC-Port ist wirklich grottenschlecht.
Grottenschlecht.
Warum heißt der Anus?
Warum nennt man sich Anus?
Kann man daraus was ableiten?
Hm.
Vielleicht hat er gerne was in seinem Anus.
Guckt euch das Gespräch an.
Habt ihr es gesehen?
So, wir müssen jetzt noch ein paar Kills machen.
Für Bombe.
Spielen wir mal ein bisschen safe.
Achso.
Wir haben verloren.
Also wieder dasselbe Codrash wie jedes Jahr.
Ich kann das schlecht beurteilen, weil ich habe die letzten nicht mehr gespielt.
Pssst.
Zeigen wir mal ein paar Manieren.
Ich habe das letzte nicht, ich habe die letzten nicht gespielt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Es macht Spaß.
Das Game fühlt sich aber komisch an irgendwie.
Das Problem ist Call of Duties machen immer Spaß, wenn sie neu sind.
Deswegen.
Aber was habe ich gesagt, wollen wir jetzt machen?
Ich wollte irgendwas ausrüsten.
Wollte ich nicht machen, wollte vergessen.
Keine Ahnung.
Ah, meine.
Ach, ich wollte, genau, wo kann man denn seine Killstreaks jetzt, äh, Scorestreaks, steht doch sogar ganz fett da.
Also, was haben wir da, Recon Aircraft, okay, das ist das kleinste, was es gibt.
Ne, das kleinste ist der Molotow-Cocktail, Water Strike, Bombe, Artillery.
Huh, Care Package, na den Kack braucht ja kein Mensch, äh, oh, das, das will ich haben.
Das will ich haben, das sind bestimmt sowas wie Hunde, vermute ich mal.
Das sind bestimmt sowas wie Hunde aus Black Ops 1, weil das ist sauhoch, der Killstreak, hallo, 18H, das probieren wir mal zu erreichen, dass es in Team Deathmatch immer ziemlich schwer ist.
Lass doch mal ne Runde schneiden.
Lass doch mal am Anfang ne Runde schneiden.
Ich brauch unbedingt Quickdraw.
Wir nehmen einfach jetzt mal die vorgefertigte Sniper-Klasse.
Äh, Moment, ist das ne Claymore?
Perfekt, ich wollte eigentlich genau das gleiche machen, wie der Typ ne Granate rüberwerft.
Okay, komm mal, wenigstens mal einen snipen, wenigstens mal einen snipen.
Hallo?
Warum sieht der mich nicht?
Lull.
Komm her, Bonker S.
Hardscope.
Hardscope-Loop.
Knopp.
Kein Bock mehr zu snipen.
Machen wir mal genau das Umgedrehte.
Jetzt wird nicht gesniped, jetzt wird getrenchgunned.
Was ist denn das?
Jetzt wird, jetzt wird getrenchgunned.
Muss, muss sein jetzt, es geht leider nicht anders.
Ich hör was.
Oder auch nicht.
Oh.
Der stirbt jetzt, Lull.
Die ist so OP, die Shotgun.
Guck, zack.
Sogar wenn ich down bin.
Jetzt hört sich wieder an, als sind Gegner vor mir, ist es aber nicht.
Was macht denn der da?
Jetzt hab ich da so schnell draußen rumgelaufen, um ihn zu bashen.
Das manchmal hört sich an, als sind Gegner neben einem, obwohl sie es nicht sind.
Sehr, sehr merkwürdig.
Ne, ne, komm mal, jetzt machen wir was ordentliches.
Ich spiel mal ein bisschen Assault Rifle, wollt ich immer ausprobieren.
Ja, Feuermunition, das ist der größte OP-Kack im ganzen Game.
Was auch immer man sich dabei gedacht hat.
Das Ding ist ziemlich ungenau für ein Assault Rifle, die, da sind ja die SMGs genauer.
Hinter mir.
Oh, oh.
Kann man Gegner anhand ihrer Schritte ordnen? Ja.
Es geht, es geht halbwegs gut, ich finde es geht besser als in anderen Call of Duty's, als in den letzten paar, die ich gespielt hab.
Warum macht das Ding keinen Schaden?
Der schießt auch schneller als ich, hab ich gedacht.
Oh, da kam mir das nur so vor.
Headglitch.
Komm, ihr müsst jetzt hier langkommen, Leute.
Irgendwie macht das Ding zu wenig Schaden.
Ah, wieder mal eine Spray and Pray SMG.
Beste Waffe.
Da ist einer drinnen, ne?
Flanken wir mal in der Mitte durch.
Was ist denn hier was? Hier ist nix.
Wo ist hier was?
Suche Gegner.
Ich krieg grad so krass auf die Fresse, nur auf die Fresse.
Wie gefällt dir das Spiel?
Das macht Spaß, aber jedes Call of Duty macht Spaß, wenn es neu ist.
Was zum Teufel geht mit den Gegnern gerade ab?
Das Ding macht übertriebenes Damage für eine SMG.
Der Face Peter.
Moment, ist der hinter mir gespaw... der ist hinter mir gespawnt, ey.
Erste Spawnposition.
Spray and Pray.
F.T.W.
Jetzt bin ich hinter ihm gespawnt, das wird immer fairer.
Jetzt ist er hinter mir gespawnt.
Der SMG wurde schon genervt?
Echt jetzt?
Ich hab keine Patchnotes gelesen oder so.
Wir müssen hierfür noch mal ein bisschen was freispielen.
Der denkt jetzt, ich geh oben lang.
Jetzt denkt er sich, wo ist er denn?
Wo ist er denn?
Ne?
Der denkt jetzt, ich geh oben lang.
Oh, das war jetzt nix.
Oh, das sind ganz schön viele da.
F.U.C.K.
Wie viele, wie viele Gegner bitte?
Wie viele waren das?
Das waren fünf Stück und nicht drumherum.
Gibt es eine Burstwaffe?
Ich hab noch keine gefunden.
Es gibt halbautomatische Sniper, es gibt Bowle-Action-Sniper, SMGs, ne Doppelläufige Shotgun, ne Pump-Action-Shotgun, aber ne Burstwaffe wie die Farmer's hab ich noch nicht gesehen.
Oh, ich hab wieder nen hässlichen...
Hab ich nicht.
Warten wir mal kurz, bis wir sehen, wo die Gegner sind.
Perfekte Granate.
Der Typ lebt noch.
Das Ding macht kein Damage!
Ja, Tremor finde ich auch.
Also, ich hatte auf die letzten Call of Duty's überhaupt keinen Bock, das hier macht.
Halbwegs Bock.
Aber es ist halt neu.
Und...
Es ist halt so, die Leute kriegen ja immer erst mit der Zeit raus, was richtig abfuckt und nervt.
Ich muss hier unbedingt nach der Runde, muss ich mal raus, Perks und Killstreaks und sowas in Ruhe angucken.
Hallo Leoxzock.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie lange die Beta noch läuft.
Pssiu, pssiu.
Ich kann mir aber nicht vorstellen, dass das ein Game ist, weil es ist halt so das typische stupide Team-Deathmatch, zumindest in dem Spielmodus halt.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das ein Game ist, was ich ein Jahr spielen kann.
So, jetzt muss ich mir erstmal in Ruhe Perks und Killstreaks und so nochmal angucken.
Was, bis 5. November? Okay, das ist ja noch ein bisschen.
Kann ich morgen noch ein bisschen streben?
Der Anus.
Der Name, ja.
Warum?
Ich finde, mein Name ist der Beste für Call of Duty, oder?
Also, für Call of Duty kann man eigentlich nicht besser heißen als...
So, jetzt muss ich mir das mal in Ruhe angucken.
Killstreaks, das lassen wir mal so.
Das bringt es gar nicht.
Das ist quasi ein Heli, sowas wie ein Attack-Helikopter.
Das lassen wir mal so.
22, welches Level bin ich?
Welches Level bin ich?
19, okay.
Die probieren wir da mal aus, wenn wir es haben.
So, wie funktioniert das jetzt mit den Perks?
Mal angenommen, ich...
Ah, so geht das.
Okay, das hier unten ist wahrscheinlich, je nach Division, feste Perks, so wie ich das verstehe.
Und das hier neben sind halt, ja, Perks, die man sich ausrüsten kann.
Aber anscheinend nur eins.
Was gibt es denn da so?
Das ist hier für...
RPG-Zeug.
RPG und Influb.
Lookout, das heißt, man sieht die Namen früher.
Das ist Scavenger.
Reload Fast End-Filesprinting, das ist cool.
Take Two Primary, das ist quasi Overkill.
Take Two Attachments, okay.
Fire Guns Wilds...
Oh, das brauchen wir.
Das brauchen wir für unsere...
für unsere Shotgun-Klasse.
Enemy, your damage appears on...
Minimap.
Das ist bestimmt auch nicht schlecht.
Ich glaube, das ist gut, wenn man einfach so die Randomness, die es in Call of Duty nun mal gibt, ein bisschen reduzieren will.
Das ist gut, dann sieht man, wo der Typ seine...
dann sieht man, wo der Typ seine Artillerie hingesetzt hat und sowas.
Bang.
Na.
Wisst ihr, das verstehe ich nicht.
Warum kann man nicht jetzt hier schon hinschreiben, was es macht?
Es ist ja schön und gut, dass ich es erst ab Rang 23 nehmen kann, aber wie wäre es denn, wenn man jetzt schon wüsste, was es ist?
Also, das ist ganz gut. Im Rennen sprinten, perfekt.
So, das machen wir uns noch...
Okay, das heißt...
Hier sieht man die...
die Perks für die einzelnen Divisionen.
Okay.
Ja, dann spielen wir erstmal Airborne weiter frei, würde ich sagen.
Und das ist... oh, das ist für die ganzen Ghost-Spieler.
Da weiß... da weiß ich jetzt schon Sachen, die mich abfacken werden.
Silent Movement, das ist so OP, das ist must have.
Also, wenn man... wenn man das vielleicht später rankt und ein bisschen...
koordiniert spielt. Silent Movement, das ist OP, das braucht man.
Man wird wahrscheinlich rankt später nicht mehr ohne... ohne hier Mountain spielen können.
Okay. Leveln wir das Ding nochmal ein bisschen.
Das könnte man dafür gut nehmen hier.
Take two primary weapons. Ne, das brauchen wir nicht.
Im Prinzip ist Reload faster echt geil.
Machen wir das mal.
Okay. Weiter geht's.
Spielen wir nochmal eine Runde Team Deathmatch.
Die letzte MP ist ziemlich krass, okay.
Ja, das ist gut. Ich... ich spiele ja quasi eh gerade Airborne frei.
Dann werden wir die ja demnächst haben, hoffe ich.
Bei Level... Level 22 gibt's... gibt's noch eine.
Und dann müssen wir mal gucken, welche kommt, wenn man Airborne hat.
Guck, ich kann jetzt reloaden.
Ah, das ist geil. Ich kann ballern... ich kann ballern, während ich sprinte. Geil.
Da stehe ich drauf, auf sowas in so Games.
Okay, vielleicht soll ich nicht in drei Gegner reinrennen, aber...
Das ist geil.
Das ist gut. Rennen und... und gleichzeitig sprinten. Beste.
Beste Erfindung.
Komm her. Komm her. Komm her. Komm her, Headglitch.
Flanken da jetzt mal.
Sollen die sich da mal kloppen.
Hier ist ja gar nichts mehr.
YOLO.
Hinter mir.
Rennen und gleichzeitig...
Hab ich das gesagt, ja?
Ich meine natürlich Rennen und gleichzeitig schießen.
Aber Rennen und gleichzeitig sprinten ist auch was.
Das ist ein doppelter Boost hier.
Ich krieg keine Kills.
Oh, das ist geil.
Das finde ich super. Einfach... einfach reinchargen und ballern dabei.
Vielleicht ein bisschen zu aggressiv gerade, so minimal, ne?
Was ist eigentlich aus dem Arbeitskollegen geworden,
der mich vor...
Meinst du Felix oder was?
Der arbeitet immer noch hier.
Da, wo ich arbeite.
Achtung, die kommen jetzt hier raus.
Da werden sie gefasht.
Kommt her.
Oh, deckt.
Oh, jetzt kommen sie von hinten.
Den holen wir. Den holen wir uns.
Den holen wir uns.
Faschen.
Wir waren leider nicht schnell genug.
Fritz.
Fritz wird getroppt.
Das ist geil.
Das ist so geil.
Sprinten und Rennen.
Best...
Oh, fuck.
Beste.
Man bringt sich da halt auch mal schnell in Situationen, wo man auf den Sack kriegt.
Moment.
Ich war da oben dran.
Komm her.
Ihr wollt jetzt langlaufen.
Das weiß ich.
Moment.
Oh, shit.
Das ist zwar geil, wenn man reinchargen kann und dabei ballern.
Aber so möglichst viel bringen tut es jetzt ja auch nicht.
Man kriegt halt...
Guckt euch das mal an.
Man kriegt halt permanent auf den Sack.
Aber es macht Bock.
Chargen und ballern.
Das habe ich an jedem Call of Duty gerne gemacht.
Am besten jetzt noch unendlich Sprint.
Am besten jetzt noch unendlich Sprint und dann ist alles gut.
Verdienst du mit YouTube trotz Inaktivität noch mehr als mit deiner eigenen Arbeit?
Nee.
Da hängt ja einiges davon ab.
Und äh...
Vor allem, wenn man halt nicht aktiv ist.
Das ist ja nicht nur, dass man dann quasi keine...
Dass man dann keine Views und neue Abos und sowas kriegt.
Das ist dann auch nicht sonderlich interessant für ein...
Alter.
Für ein...
Für irgendwelche Firmen oder so dann da was zu machen.
Ich wollte ja was mit Alienware machen, aber da haben wir jetzt erstmal gesagt, nee,
lassen wir mal bleiben.
Bis ich wieder ein bisschen mehr mache.
Das habe sogar ich vorgeschlagen, weil das hat keinen Sinn.
Das sollen ja alle auch was von haben.
So, jetzt muss ich mich mal ein bisschen konzentrieren wieder.
Oh, oh, oh.
Beste.
So geil.
Sprinten und ballern dabei.
NAA.
Juck die Nase.
Hast du freitags noch frei wegen YouTube?
Nee, ich habe montags frei.
Tschuldige.
Immer montags frei.
Ich würde jetzt ja mal gerne wieder ein bisschen was reißen gerade.
Aber Team Deathmatch, ein paar Stunden, das ermüdet einfach so.
Wo ist denn der hinter mir los?
Gucken wir mal, ob wir da lebend rüberkommen.
Oh.
Oh, wisst ihr, was das Schlimme ist?
Man kann nicht...
Man kann...
Man kann jetzt nicht hier aus der Lobby raus.
Weißt du, wie lange du noch streamst?
Keine Ahnung.
Solange ich doch Bock habe.
Aber macht es keinen Bock.
8-9.
Das ist ja hier...
Das ist ein sehr zersetztes Game noch nie gespielt.
Ähm.
Ich streame jetzt schon 2 Stunden.
Also ein bisschen mache ich noch.
Es ist ja erst 12.
Abend gehe ich mir mit Kaboom All You Can Eat Asia futtern.
Aber erst später.
Ich habe jetzt noch Zeit.
Der Rüdiger Franziskus.
Nee.
Rüdiger Franzirkus, sozusagen.
Kann man ja nicht ausstellen.
Gibt.
Ähm.
Also bis 22 spielen wir auf jeden Fall noch.
Weil ich will die letzte SMG ausprobieren.
Heißt das hier, dass die zusammen in einer Party sind?
Oder was?
Was heißen diese Köppe?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Was sagt Kaboom?
Zurzeit zockt?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe mit dem Krieger...
Habe ich gerade eigentlich nichts mal Großes zu tun.
Ich kann verstehen, dass er lieber strebt, anstatt Youtube zu machen.
Also ich sehe ihn ja.
So oft auf Twitter.
Äh.
Auf Twitter.
Auf Twitch.
Weißt du noch, wie der Shop hieß, wo du damals Black Ops 1 vorbestellst?
Ähm.
Das war so ein Schweizer Shop.
Games Only?
Gibt es sowas?
Kann das sein?
Sowas total überteuertes?
Oh.
Ich muss weg.
Fuck.
Sowas total überteuertes war.
Das hat damals irgendwie 70 Euro gekostet.
Hat das jetzt auch gekostet?
Ich weiß nicht.
Gute Option.
Hat damals 70 Euro gekostet.
Und war halt trotzdem schneller da als deutsche Shops.
Weil sie das halt vor Release schon verschickt haben.
Und wahrscheinlich DHL an der Grenze gegeben haben.
Fuck fuck fuck fuck.
Ey, wo sind denn die alle?
Die PPSH-Spielerin nach Amberweder, die war auch extrem gut.
Die Waffe hört sich an, ohne Schalldämpfer wie mit Schalldämpfer.
Kann das sein?
Ja, ne?
Eigentlich kein Unterschied.
Nee.
Stopp.
Ich glaube, der Sound, die haben einfach den Sound verwechselt.
Ich glaube, nichts.
Die Waffe ist über Range, richtig, ja, sack.
Tut dir das mal an.
Lol, was sitzt da in der Ecke?
World of Games, ich weiß es nicht, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich kann mich da nicht mehr, ich glaube, Games, ich glaube, Games Only hieß das.
Ich glaube, Games Only hieß das.
Mal eine andere Waffe ausprobieren.
Oh, wir haben Eva gekillt.
Jetzt spawnen sie hinter uns, das ist Call of Duty, darf man nicht vergessen.
Ist immer so, die spawnen immer hinter einem.
Ne, okay, unsere Leute spawnen noch da.
Da kommt rechts was.
Komm her.
Aha.
Bashing.
Geht, schreckt.
Am besten ist langsam, habe ich echt das Gefühl, man bleibt einfach an einer Stelle stehen und guckt in eine Richtung.
Jetzt kommen sie wahrscheinlich von hinten.
Jetzt kommen sie von hinten.
Was?
Ey, Call of Duty Tote.
Immer da, wo du nicht hinguckst und denkst, dass da eigentlich von da keiner kommen kann, kommt einer.
Ich habe alles gecheckt, ne, nichts war da, bam, tot.
Oh, wir sind ein bisschen unterlegen, kann das sein?
So ein ganz kleines bisschen.
Bam.
Oh, ich dachte, der schrebt wenigstens.
Ah.
Geiles Timing, ja, ne, Hans, bestes Timing.
Faires Match, GG.
Ja, wir wollen 22 werden.
Der liegt da oben, ich weiß, dass der da oben liegt.
Liegt, ne.
Komm her.
Ey.
Ja, meine Team-Mates, oh ne.
Die Unterzahl ist halt echt schwer.
Spray, spray.
Den holen wir uns noch.
Ja, natürlich, von allen Seiten.
Aber ich meine, es ist halt einfach mal 3 gegen 6.
2, ja, 2 gegen 6, aber fast 3 gegen 6.
Ja, ich finde es gut, dass man die Schritte, finde ich auch.
Gut, dass man die Schritte wieder hört.
Ey.
Das geht halt gar nicht.
Die, ich muss die, die Type, die Type 8, 20 oder Waffe 8, 20 Ding muss ich aber ausprobieren.
Das macht einen absoluten Schmerz.
U.P. Eindruck, das Ding.
Ah, wir haben wieder Leute.
Yeah.
Achtung, jetzt.
Jetzt wird er, jetzt wird er geschreckt.
Krass geschreckt.
Komm her.
Da kommt noch einer.
Und links.
Ey, ich wusste, dass du links bist.
Und ich habe mich noch vorher geschossen, aber nee.
Aber nee.
Was ist das?
Guckt euch mal die Hand.
Habt ihr die Hand gesehen?
Ich habe gerade die Hand von der Waffe.
Guckt euch mal die Hand an.
Guckt euch mal die Hand an der Waffe an.
Die sieht hässlich aus.
Guckt mal, guckt mal.
Guckt euch mal die Hand an.
Was ist denn das?
Das sieht echt kacke aus.
Ja.
Natürlich.
Okay.
Die wollten es nicht anders.
Ja.
Wenn ihr das so wollt, dann spielt ihr als Shotgun.
Ist halt ein Handschuh.
Ja, aber ganz schön.
Ein dreckiger Handschuh.
Dann mit der Pumpgun.
Goethe-Straße.
Louis Vitorstor.
Zahl die Kollektion bar.
Fick auf Sponsor.
Dann mit der Pumpgun, wenn es sonst nicht geht.
Dann mit der Pumpgun.
Why so laggy?
Because.
Wall of Duty.
Meinst du den Stream oder meinst du hier Gameplay?
Weil der Stream ist echt Jeff Geass.
Mehr geht nicht.
Die sind so OP, die Brandmunition.
Kommen wir an.
Jaeroceu Ne sorta
Mal, mal!
Sucht skill!
Bam!
Leckererole.
Ja die wichtigen Sachen muss man ja auch können.
Ich habe Hunger!
Über den Kohlhampf.
Ich gehe mal kurz gucken wegen dem Essen.
Ich bin um 2 Minuten wieder im八600m in die Quadri.
Bis die nächste Runde wieder losgeht.
So.
Weiter geht es.
richtig gesehen habe. Gibraltar,
diese Schneemap
und die.
Wir bringen es hart.
Ihr denkt jetzt,
dass ich links dann gehe, ne?
Triple, triple, triple.
Wo ist der nächste?
Bam!
Was?
Was? Was?
Was? Suchskill.
Moment.
Ich bin quasi direkt vor der Nase
wieder gespawnt, ne?
Call of Duty spawnen, lol.
Rumgecharge.
Also Typ 28,
von dem Ding werde ich so oft gekillt, das brauche ich auch.
Das muss ich auch mal testen.
Wie OP das Ding wirklich ist.
Da ist ein Gegner.
Bonk AS.
Call of Duty, immer.
Immer von hinten.
Fühlt sich beim Zuschauen an,
als wären es weniger als 60 FPS.
Ist das so?
Also ich gucke es mir gerade im Vorschau an.
Ich gucke mir das gerade in der Vorschau an.
Ich habe null Frametrops.
Wir stellen das jetzt mal um.
Wir stellen das jetzt mal von Game Capture
auf Window Capture um.
Was natürlich nicht funktioniert, ne?
Vielleicht geht es dann besser.
Window?
Ne, ich will Window.
Ich will Fullscreen.
Okay, probieren wir das mal aus jetzt.
Ich stelle das jetzt mal um von...
Ich kann Call of Duty nicht capturen.
Mit Window Capture geht nicht.
Geht nur mit Game Capture.
Keine Ahnung.
Was da ist.
Ich darf übrigens im Game wieder nicht rumklicken.
Ich glaube, das Game ist wieder abgestürzt.
Hallo?
Game?
Ah, jetzt ist es aus.
Vielleicht ist es jetzt besser, wenn ich neu starte.
Also wenn ich das Game neu starte, vielleicht geht es jetzt besser.
Klar.
Mein Rechner spackt auch richtig rum.
Also das liegt nicht am Stream.
Das muss an dem Game liegen.
Ich sehe es hier auch.
Also ich habe es in-Game auch ab und zu mal ruckeln, aber...
So schlimm kommt es mir nicht vor.
Was hältst du vom Spiel?
Ja, macht Spaß.
Ist halt ein neues Call of Duty, was am Anfang immer Spaß macht.
Oh nein, mein Mikrofon wieder.
Oh, das Game.
Ich mache das Mikrofon leiser.
Das ist wirklich nervig, dass das Game immer das Mikrofon umstellt.
Das fuckt mich richtig ab.
Da denke ich doch nicht dran.
Also wenn ich mir jetzt die Vorschau angucke, läuft das besser.
Ah, das Game ist wieder abgestürzt.
Oh Mann, ey, der PC-Port ist so krütze.
So eine Scheiße.
Ich glaube, ich muss mich jetzt wieder auf die Vorschau kümmern.
Ich muss mich jetzt wieder auf die Vorschau kümmern.
Sag mir mal, wie es jetzt läuft.
Sledgehammer-PC-Ports, lull.
Ja, das stimmt.
Was war denn das letzte Sledgehammer-Ghosts?
Ne, ähm...
Was war denn das letzte Ravensoft-Sledgehammer-Call of Duty?
Was war denn das nochmal?
Atwan's Warfare, ne?
Atwan's Warfare? War das Atwan's Warfare?
Das war auch kacke.
Hatte es nicht einen 60 FPS-Log und so einen Dreck?
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern,
wo sie gesagt haben, ja,
wir lieben PC-Spieler,
aber Foff-Changer gibt es nicht.
Und dann hat jemand
ein Tool programmiert, was quasi in der
Config-Datei das Foff geändert hat.
Danach haben sie gesagt, ja, jetzt wird er gebannt.
Also ich glaube, sie haben nie einen gebannt, aber
man kann ja auch schon seine eigenen
Käufer
recken, ne?
Wir gucken uns gleich mal...
Ich gucke mir mal nebenbei auf dem zweiten Bildschirm
die Spielerzahlen an.
Steam Stats.
Hallo?
Steam? Ich darf nichts schreiben.
Das Game hat meine
Tastatur ge-
ge-crapped. Ich darf nichts machen auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Team Deathmatch.
Steam Stats.
Stats.
Stats in Deutschland.
Call of Duty.
46k.
Im Vergleich zu
Puppke mit einer Million.
Loll.
Ah, ich habe wieder Input.
Auch klasse.
Dab.
Geht jetzt.
So, läuft das Game jetzt besser oder immer noch so kacke?
Weil ich habe keine Frametrops und nichts, ne?
Das sieht aus wie unschöne 30 FPS.
Okay.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Das...
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das an meinem OBS und Stream liegt.
Eher schlecht, okay.
Weil in meiner Vorschau sieht das super aus.
Na gut.
Naja, wirklich schön sieht es bei mir auch in der Vorschau nicht aus.
Was ist denn das für ein Kack?
Ich meine, meine CPU ist auch null ausgelastet.
Also außer halt für das, was für Call of Duty das ist.
Keine Frametrops und nichts.
Ich mach mal kurz Stream aus und wieder an.